Con mi mejor traje anti-TED.
Y hubo un acto conocido como el acto del Oráculo.
En este acto, los miembros del público,
como Uds. lo han hecho hoy,
escribían preguntas secretas,
el tipo de preguntas que harían a un vidente.
Después guardaban la pregunta en un sobre,
escribían por fuera sus iniciales y su lugar aproximado de asiento.
Después, el Oráculo, el que leía mentes, tomaba los sobres uno a uno,
no los abría,
pero intentaba adivinar qué pregunta estaba guardada dentro.
Y si acertaba, intentaba responder a la pregunta
por la persona que la redactó.
Este espectáculo se extendió como la pólvora.
Creo que es una prueba sobre el aspecto seductor
de una figura poderosa ofreciéndote respuestas simples y sencillas
a las complicadas y sutiles preguntas
y ansiedades de la vida.
Gracias a los que hoy escribieron preguntas.
Yo no las he visto. Sé que alguien las guarda.
Muchísimas gracias.
Ahora las tomaré. Gracias a todos los que ayudaron.
Probablemente debería decir un par de cosas antes de empezar.
Si soy totalmente honesto...
Primero, no puedo ver a través de los sobres.
Están sellados. Son gruesos y negros.
Lo sabrán si han escrito uno de ellos. Es imposible.
Lo segundo y más importante, no conozco a nadie aquí
y nadie me está siguiendo la corriente.
No se trata de eso.
Tercero...
no creo para nada que yo tenga ningún don psicológico
y mucho menos psíquico.
Así que, comencemos.
Nop.
(Risas)
Bueno, este...
Oh, bien.
Bueno, este es interesante. Aquí hay un par.
Quizás empiece con este.
Este es interesante porque la escritura es ondulada.
Digamos que sube y baja,
que normalmente significa, no siempre
que ni siquiera la persona sabe la respuesta a la pregunta.
Así que suele ser una pregunta sobre el futuro, ¿no?
Eso suele suponer incertidumbre.
Así que diría que es una mujer.
Respecto a la edad, es difícil saberlo por esta mínima escritura...
Yo diría que quizás 30 o 40, pero vamos a averiguarlo.
Dice... y una pregunta sobre el futuro,
dice: "JN, centro".
Así que es alguien de esta sección central de aquí.
Si piensan que es alguno de ustedes
¿podrían hacer ruido?
Me resulta un poco difícil ver el centro.
Hola, salúdanos.
J...
¿Jane? ¿Jessica?
Jessica: Sí.
Darren Brown: ¿cuál de ellos? J: Jessica.
DB: Gracias, lo suponía. Unos murmullos de aprobación, por favor.
(Risas)
Me vale.
Bien, no te preguntaré tu edad, pero
¿es una pregunta cuya esencia trata sobre el futuro?
J: (Asiente) DB: ¿Sí?
Jessica: Sí. DB: Sí. Bien.
Bien. ¿Qué hemos preguntado? ¿Qué pregunta Jessica sobre el futuro?
¿Voy bien con lo de los 30, tirando a 40?
Jessica: Lo acepto. Me vale.
(Risas)
DB: Bien, es importante,
porque hacemos preguntas distintas dependiendo de la edad.
Di "lo acepto" otra vez.
Jessica: Lo acepto.
DB: ¿Virginia? ¿Es usted de Virginia? Jessica: Sí.
DB: Sí. Bien...
(Risas)
Creo que tenemos a una mujer.
Creo que tenemos a una mujer que quiere irse de Virginia.
Creo que está haciendo planes,
y quieres saber si las cosas van a salir bien o no.
Enséñame tus manos.
¿El otro lado para ver las uñas?
Vale, creo que tienes una granja
y quieres saber si venderás tu granja y te marcharás de Virginia, ¿verdad?
¿Es correcto?
Jessica: Totalmente, esa es la pregunta.
DB: Bien. Genial. Gracias. ¡Es una gran pregunta!
¿Cuál era la pregunta real? ¿Qué escribió?
Jessica: "¿Venderé la granja en Virginia?"
DB: ¿Venderás la granja?
Bien, mira, es una buena pregunta si simulan ser psíquicos,
porque trata sobre el futuro,
lo que significa que puedo darles un sí o un no.
No significa nada. No hay manera de verificarlo.
Y algo peligroso de hacer...
si digo sí o no se te quedará dando vueltas en la cabeza,
y puede empezar a afectar las decisiones que tomes.
Es una accción peligrosa. Pero...
(Risas)
Sí, creo que venderás la granja
porque creo que eres el tipo de persona
que consigue lo que quiere de la mejor manera.
Creo que cuando se quieren cosas tiendes a centrarte en ellas
en detrimento de otras cosas
en las que sabes que deberías centrarte más.
¿Estás de acuerdo?
Culta, pasaste un par de años en...
Dí "sí" otra vez, rápido. Jessica: Sí.
DB: ¿No? Jessica: No.
DB: ¿California? ¿Berkeley? Solo supongo, pero...
Jessica: Fui a Berkeley, sí. ¡Deja de hacer esto!
DB: Así que es un sí.
¡Y hace poco has estado en India también!
Hay algo por ahí, ¿verdad? ¿o no?
Jessica: Sí, acabo de volver de la India.
DB: Digo que sí, pero no quiero decirlo como si estuviera destinado a ocurrir,
que no lo está, y tienes que asumir la responsabilidad. ¿Contesté a tu pregunta?
J: Sí. DB: Siéntate. Hagamos otro.
(Aplausos)
AH, ¿también en el centro? AH.
Este será un hombre, un poco mayor. Por la carta quizás de 40 y muchos.
AH, levántate por mí si piensas que eres tú.
AH. Hola, demos un micrófono a este chico.
Tan rápido como podamos, una cámara sería increíble.
¡Oh, mira eso! Párate. No te muevas. No te muevas.
Quédate completamente quieto.
¿Estás de pie? ¿Dónde estás?
Hombre: Estoy de pie. No soy tan bajo.
DB: Bien.
Bien, lo has cambiado.
Has hecho algo al levantarte.
¿Sí o no? ¿Has puesto algo aquí...?
Ahora mismo no lo estás haciendo, pero al levantarte, sí.
Tiene que ver con tu pierna o tu pie izquierdo. ¿Sí o no?
Hombre: Sí.
DB: Vale. Nos hizo una señal clara al levantarse.
Pon todo el peso en tu lado izquierdo y dime "sí".
Hombre: Sí.
DB: Sácate la mano del bolsillo y pon el peso en el otro lado,
cambia las manos del micrófono y dí "sí".
Hombre: Sí.
DB: ¿Tienes dislocado
el dedo gordo del pie del lado izquierdo?
Hombre: Sí.
DB: Muchas gracias. Genial. ¡Muy buena! Siéntate.
¿Me pasas el micrófono? Voy a cambiar de micrófono esta vez.
¿Uno para aquí arriba? Gracias.
Muchas gracias. Aquí está perfecto.
Voy a cambiar de micrófono porque...
Todavía pueden oírme, ¿verdad?
Voy a vendarme los ojos.
Lo haré ahora mismo para no tener pruebas cuando se levanten.
No puedo ver donde ponen las manos,
cómo responden a lo que les digo,
y tampoco puedo ver lo que la persona de al lado hace.
Cuando saben las respuestas a la pregunta, siempre resulta muy fácil.
No tendré esas ventajas,
pero por extraño que suene,
esto me libera. Y quiero
que los libere a Uds. también,
Si no escribieron una pregunta,
pero desearían haberlo hecho,
todavía pueden participar.
El objetivo de escribir una pregunta
es que te crea una especie de fórmula corta en la cabeza.
Así que si puedes encontrar preguntas en tu cabeza,
hacerla clara y concisa, envíamela.
Yo intentaré hacerlo sin que haya nada escrito.
Así que comiencen a mandarme preguntas con sus nombres.
"Me llamo...", seguido del nombre que sea.
y "¿qué le ocurre a mi pie?" o lo que sea.
O sea, nombre y pregunta.
Ya hay alguien.
Supongo que estás por la primera fila porque tu nombre está muy claro.
Siento que estás en el centro, por delante.
Bien, déjame que... ¿Allan?
Siento que hay un Allan.
Y debes de estar muy cerca del principio, hacia el centro, creo.
Parece que viene por aquí enfrente...
Hay un hombre, de unos 60 años, algo así.
Allan: Sí
DB: ¿Tienes un micrófono? Genial, gracias.
Di "para" cuando llegue a ti para saber donde estás,
y hacia donde mirar.
Allan: Para.
DB: ¿Eres Capricornio? Allan: Sí.
DB: Allan tiene algo en su cabeza.
¿Lo oyen? ¿Oyen la reticencia en su voz?
Esto será algo bastante difícil.
Yo creo... A ver, dime "sí" otra vez.
Allan: Sí.
DB: Esto tiene que ser...
bueno, no.
Es un acceso, una contraseña, para acceder a algo.
Dime sí o no. ¿Hay en tu cabeza algo relacionado con una contraseña?
Allan: Sí.
DB: Una contraseña de computadora, ¿algo así?
DB: Excelente.
(Risas)
En ese caso, voy a terminar ya... Déjame...
Si no me equivoco,
todo el mundo van a saberla ahora, y millones de personas potencialmene.
¿La cambiarás, verdad?
Allan: Por supuesto.
(Risas)
DB: Di "por supuesto" otra vez? Allan: Por supuesto.
DB: Bien. Si es una palabra... Me imagino que es una palabra...
Visualiza la palabra escrita frente a ti,
en mayúsculas bien grandes, en negrita,
y mientras la miras, piensa en una letra en cualquier parte de esa palabra.
No la digas en voz alta.
Piensa simplemente en una letra por el medio.
¿Ya la tienes? Allan: Sí.
DB: Bien, recuérdala.
Eh, la has cambiado, bueno.
Has cambiado de idea.
Creo que al final...
has elegido la "B", ¿verdad?
Allan: No.
No es esa.
DB: Bien, ¿es una "I"?. Allan: Sí.
DB: Pero antes era una "B". Allan: Sí.
DB: Sí, cambiaste de idea. Cambió de idea.
(Risas)
Bien, imagínatela escrita.
Sigue repitiéndola en tu cabeza.
¿Tocas la batería, verdad?
Allan: Sí.
DB: Olvídate de eso ahora, olvídalo.
Ahora concéntrate solo en la palabra.
(Risas)
Mi trabajo es vender una historia,
e intento hacer esto para conseguir dirigir su atención
hacia una cosa que quiero que Uds. creen importante.
Ignorar otras cosas que quiero que ignoren
y después juntar esos nudos narrativos
para inventarles una historia sobre lo que hago ahora.
Esto funciona porque somos criaturas de crear historias.
Lo hacemos todos los días.
Salimos a este mundo complejo y sutil
lleno de personas complejas y sutiles, como tú y yo, Allan,
y las reducimos a estos personajes ordenados
que cuadran en cualquier historia que contemos.
Y decimos "ella es insegura", "él es arrogante", y otras cosas,
y son simplemente historias como la de que les puedo leer la mente.
¿Verdad que en este momento, estás pensando en vender tu empresa?
Allan: Correcto.
DB: ¿Tiene algo que ver con la piel?
Allan: Sí.
DB: El cuidado de la piel o algo así.
DB: Creo que la razón por la que amo hacer esto
es que me recuerda que tengo que estar más vivo y alerta
a la complejidad y la sutileza de lo que es real,
y que siempre hay otras cosas ocurriendo, que no conocemos.
Así, podemos estancarnos menos, ser más amables con los demás
porque así siempre podemos reconocer el miedo detrás de su estrés,
y no necesitamos tomar todo a la defensiva,
y podemos empezar a ver las historias por lo que son
y reconocer que todo en la vida no gira entorno a nosotros.
¡Ay!
Tu contraseña... ¿Dónde estás? ¿Dónde está?
Allan: Aquí.
DB: Levántate. Tu contraseña es "ariboy".
A-r-i-b-o-y? ¿Correcto? Allan: Sí, correcto.
DB: Muchas gracias. Muchas gracias, de verdad.
Gracias.